i think more people think i'm american
than australian which is kind of funny
the older i get
the more i hear that especially when i
tell people like wow you're from
australia
but that's my roots you know that's
where i'm from is where i grew up
[Music]
i'm ben simmons from the philadelphia
76ers i feel like everyone makes
sacrifices
i say one of my sacrifices would be
leaving my family at
16 to come to america that was the
sacrifice for me
at a young age that i took to follow my
passion i was playing basketball
that shifted a lot it was just a
different system and just a different
lifestyle
to me this this country is built off you
know all types of different
nationalities
everyone has different situations people
come from different backgrounds and
cultures
but that's what's you know so special
about you know america and countries
like australia is
the diversity is incredible and it's
what makes the country
to me the american dream is being able
to follow your passion
and living in freedom i think you know
everybody finds
you know what they really want to do
with time
my passion changes as i evolve so you
know new things new opportunities come
along the way
but if i'm passionate about i'm going to
chase it
you